Hi I'm Deadpool the other Jolly guy in a
red suit with a Lap worth sitting on here
to tell you happy holidays in the spirit of
this most festive time of year I've decided
to release my holiday cheer all over the world
how you ask well you naughty stocking stuffers
brace yourselves because starting today
you're getting not one not two but twelve
Glorious Days of Deadpool so sit back hold on
to your ornaments guzzle a little eggnog at
least that looks like eggnog and prepare yourself
because it's time for Saint Wade to put the wind
in Winter Wonderland
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie happy holidays
this will be my video for the secret Deadpool
movie that Ryan Reynolds Just revealed that's
right Ryan Reynolds and the people who write all
the Deadpool movies they're the same ones that
are riding Deadpool 3 right now actually made a
Deadpool Christmas movie so I'll explain what's
going on and the funny thing too is that Santa
Claus is a real Marvel character I'll explain
that too plus the week before Christmas and all
around town b-ball fans were dying to watch LeBron
Steph and Russell throw down spring back to short
shorts who wear short shorts I do I wear shirts
a basketball Miracle right here on Christmas
Day stuffed into our stockings by the Jolly NBA
join us for games oh and something else cool in
between all the dunks a sneak peek of Deadpool
we hope you've been nice if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos I'll be doing a bunch of Deadpool videos
as we get ready for Deadpool 3 also because it
is the holidays they're releasing the Guardians
of the Galaxy holiday special which is a prequel
to Guardians of the Galaxy 3 I'll be doing a bunch
of videos for that this week too recently Ryan
Reynolds explained that they wrote and prepared
a secret Deadpool movie in 2018 a couple years ago
after Deadpool 2 had been released and they were
going to release it during the Christmas season
but it got lost in the shuffle he says when Disney
bought Fox a lot of movies of all kinds that fox
was working on were canceled during that period
a couple years ago when the buyout went down not
just the fox Marvel movies they had planned but
the Deadpool Christmas movie was meant to be a
completely separate completely different movie
from the earlier version of Deadpool 3 that Ryan
Reynolds had planned to make before Disney bought
Fox which they'd already plotted out the funny
thing about that earlier version of Deadpool 3
is that it was also going to be a Deadpool
Wolverine team-up movie The only difference
in that one is that it was going to be a much
smaller Road Trip movie with just the two of
them Easy Rider or midnight run style and now the
Deadpool 3 Deadpool Wolverine movie is meant to
be a much bigger Multiverse movie incorporating
elements of the fox Marvel Universe the main 616
MCU the TVA Mobius other characters from Loki
and it's more in the vibe of Deadpool kills
the fox Marvel Universe I've already done a much
bigger video video just for the Deadpool 3 trailer
they released so I'll link it at the end of this
and down in the description below the Deadpool
Christmas movie would have been much smaller in
scope and it would have taken the place of Once
Upon a Deadpool which was their constellation
Christmas movie by the holidays thought it'd be
fun rpg-13 it's a family movie also money also
Disney but it wasn't really a legit Christmas
movie it was just a PG-13 cut of Deadpool 2 meant
to be released so that they could earn more money
families could buy extra tickets for the younger
kids that normally wouldn't have seen Deadpool 2
because it was rated R and they just released it
during that Christmas holiday later that same year
in 2018 Hollywood has had this weird thing the
last several years where they started releasing
movies multiple times really quickly looking
at you Spider-Man no way home Extended Cut and
Avengers end game but to be fair in those cases
like we did get a bunch of extra footage of Tobey
Maguire and Andrew Garfield Spider-Man which
was a lot of fun we should do this again like
I'll hang out it's nice yeah for sure yeah that's
a good idea I'll just grab your number at the end
of it the battle the plot of the Deadpool
Christmas movie would have been much more
about actual Christmas like a legit Christmas
movie as in Deadpool versus Christmas Deadpool
versus Santa Claus Deadpool Saves Christmas kind
of vibe Deadpool is like Spider-Man and that he
winds up creating most of his own problems
that he then has to fix during his movies
and the funny thing about Santa Claus is that he
is a legit Marvel character he's a very powerful
Omega Level mutant he's supposed to be one of the
most powerful mutants on the planet like we talk
about mutants coming into the MCU during Marvel
phase 4 Marvel Phase 5 Marvel phase six we just
met Namor inside black panther wakanda forever and
he's another mutant who's been alive for the past
500 years in the MCU and we're just learning about
him now Santa Claus being a mutant is Marvel's way
of explaining how he accomplishes all of his tasks
that he does during Christmas night bringing toys
to everyone around the world the biggest Deadpool
versus Santa Claus story actually happened when a
bunch of angry kids around the world hire Deadpool
to kill Santa after Christmas comes and goes
and nobody gets any toys when Deadpool goes to
actually kill him he finds out that roxan is the
real reason preventing Santa Claus from performing
his tasks giving everyone toys so he goes and he
gets rid of the problem it rocks on and then
Santa lets Deadpool give out all the undelivered
presents to all these kids and it becomes more
of a Deadpool Saves Christmas kind of story his
very first appearance in Marvel was during 1954
during Strange Tales number 34 and it wasn't like
a traditional Marvel Universe kind of story with
characters that you normally recognize it was
just a random scientist encountering a version of
Santa Claus in real life he didn't really become
an actual traditional Marvel character in the
sense until Marvel's holiday special number one
in 1991. the reason why Marvel made him a mutant
is because around the 80s the early 90s the X-Men
were becoming the most popular comic at Marvel
most popular characters so they're making crazy
money on all their X-Men stuff because they were
bringing in so many readers through their X-Men
titles Chris Claremont would do fun bonus one-off
holiday types of stories really easy for brand new
readers who weren't familiar with the continuity
to just pick up so you have like your main Phoenix
Arc Saga that are super popular everybody loves
them but then you have all these new readers just
jumping on with these one-offs after he wound
up leaving the title and Scott Lobdell took
over he wrote Marvel holiday special number one
in 1991 and that's where he turned Santa Claus
into an actual mutant inside the MCU during that
story The X-Men are decorating the Christmas tree
celebrating the holiday at the X-Mansion when
cerebro detects the most powerful mutant it's
ever registered and they discover that it winds
up being Santa Claus like he's a real person and
secretly an Omega Level mutant the X-Men follow
the source of the signal before they know that
it's Santa and find the Brotherhood of mutants who
also show up there getting the same type of signal
after they battle it out Santa Claus shows up and
uses his power to turn the Brotherhood of mutants
into action figures and then explains who he is
and what his powers are there have been a couple
different types of stories with Santa Claus across
Marvel Comics but during this era his powers were
immortality telepathy telekinesis teleportation
weather manipulation matter and molecular
manipulation and and gravity manipulation so
basically he could destroy the entire planet
than completely re-materialize it and everyone in
it with a snap of his fingers to make an Infinity
Gauntlet reference speaking of which there is the
famous story of Santa Claus wielding The Infinity
Gauntlet that everybody points to that's also
a one-off Marvel holiday story that happened a
little bit later and during that story it just
picks up with Santa Claus already wielding The
Infinity Gauntlet fighting the Illuminati and he's
more the antagonist once they calm him down and
he comes to his senses he apologizes for what
he's done and explains the only reason why he
assembled The Infinity Gauntlet was so that he
could perform all of his tasks as Santa Claus
delivering presents and Iron Man winds up helping
him out by making a bunch of Stark Tech reindeer
Bots that will help him do it like a bunch of iron
Legion Ultron Bots but that are reindeer the way
Ryan Reynolds talked about his Deadpool Christmas
movie made it sound like it wasn't like a really
huge really expensive type of movie so I actually
think that Marvel would be better off releasing
it is a holiday special one-off in some future
year like the next couple of years at some point
we're getting the the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special this week it's meant to be a
lighter type of story just like a smaller story
to set up the plot of Guardians of the Galaxy
3 a Deadpool Christmas movie would totally be in
the same type of tone like it's just a small fun
one-off type of story it's a little bit easier
for Deadpool to get away with stories like that
especially the more jokey comedic stories just
because the way the character is built and the
funny thing is that David Harbor who is now
Red Guardian in the MCU he's going to be in
the Thunderbolts movie in a big way he just made
a Christmas movie in real life where he plays a
version of Santa Claus it's called violent night
so it's more of like a hardcore Santa Claus so
it just feels like they have all the ingredients
for like a really easy really fun one-off small
Deadpool holiday special Christmas type of movie
you may remember several years ago now when they
released the first Deadpool movie because it came
out in February around Valentine's Day they spent
most of that previous Christmas holiday promoting
the movie with the 12 days of Deadpool it was
probably one of the best marketing campaigns
I've ever seen the actual plot of Deadpool 3
doesn't really have anything to do with Christmas
specifically it's more of a Deadpool kills the
fox Marvel Universe kind of story more of a larger
Multiverse story where they go from the fox Marvel
Universe to the MCU and it has a lot to do with
the TVA Mobius trying to prevent Deadpool from
destroying the Multiverse so to speak like the
whole idea that Deadpool had Cable's time travel
device and was messing with all the timelines at
the end of Deadpool 2 in the post-credits scene
and now the TVA is getting involved because he
just continued doing that and things got worse
and worse and worse and he started to destroy
the timeline and it caused larger ripples
across the Multiverse and that's why the TVA is
getting involved we'll be seeing the TVA Mobius
Loki during Loki season 2 way before Deadpool 3
comes out so when Loki season 2 trailers start
coming out we start seeing Easter eggs I'll
talk a little bit more about how Deadpool's
getting involved with that but if Marvel actually
does make a Deadpool Christmas movie or Deadpool
holiday special let me know in the comments
what you want them to do during that which
other characters do you want to see from the MCU
they could just do it with a couple of Deadpool
characters you don't need a ton of characters
for that or they could turn into a much larger
thing like that original Marvel holiday special
where they introduce Santa is an Omega level mutant
seriously it'd almost be a bad idea for them not
to try something like that everyone click here for
that brand new Deadpool 3 trailer video in easter
eggs and click here for my Loki season 2 trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!